in life and in nature there are certain
laws that we all have to live by
gravity pulls smaller objects towards
larger objects
objects in motion tend to stay in motion
and if you have bad data
any model that you make is going to be
bad too so keep watching and we'll
discuss this
i'm richard and this is richard on data
all right so one of the worst things
ever is when you train some linear
or machine learning model on a training
set then you go in to see how it
performs
and it's just awful for a lot of people
your first instinct is going to be to
try to change the hyper parameters
maybe use a neural network model instead
of a random forest model
something along those lines but quite
frankly
most of the time the issue has nothing
to do with the model that you're using
and everything to do with the data
itself so i'm going to detail six
different scenarios that can occur and
i'm going to explain how each of these
individual situations can possibly
affect the quality of your model
and i'll also have some links in the
description to some supplemental
perspectives out there from the big data
science blogs
which go into more detail on each of
these topics i'm also going to detail
these issues
within the framework of two possible
outcomes
and those are inference and prediction
if you're unfamiliar with the difference
between those terms
i'll have a card up above to a video
i've done on this and a link will be in
the description for that as well
before we get started please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
and also take less than one second of
your time to
smash the like button because that
really does help my content reach a
larger audience
i also have a link in the description of
this video to my patreon account
so if you guys would be willing to
support me in that way it would be
enormously appreciated the first
scenario
is when you just don't have enough data
now most people in statistics
intuitively understand
that if you have a higher sample size
you're going to have a more powerful
test
well the reverse of that is true too if
you have a low sample size
your test is not going to be as powerful
suppose you're building a regression
model
and it's your job to infer which
features are significant
well if you have too low of a sample
size you're going to run to a higher
type 2 error rate that is you're going
to have a higher chance of falsely
concluding that certain features
aren't significant when truthfully they
are what's going on is that as
sample size increases the variance
associated with your slope parameter
estimate
is going to decrease so putting that
another way if we have a low sample size
you're going to have a higher variance
of your slope parameter estimates in
your regression model
and that is not what we want speaking
more generally here
especially if you have way too many
covariates in your model
having a low sample size makes it a lot
more likely that you're going to overfit
obviously the whole purpose of most
machine learning exercises
is to learn patterns of your data based
on a training set
so that when new data is introduced you
can
generalize to that new data and make
accurate predictions
and you're just way more likely to over
fit your model when it's learning these
patterns based on only a few
observations
so if possible get more data and if
that's not an option
understand what you can and can't do and
how that low sample size limits your
capabilities
the second issue that can occur is when
you have covariates that
don't really have a lot of variation in
them let me give you a few examples
this one might be a little bit
counterintuitive but if you have a
continuous variable that has really low
variance
that's not necessarily a good thing if
you're using a regression model
the lower the variance is for that
variable
the higher the variance of the estimate
of that slope parameter is going to be
and that is the opposite of what you
want again another possible scenario
is that you have a categorical variable
that has tons of levels
and naturally some of these levels are
going to occur
more frequently than others some might
occur only 10 percent of the time
who knows some of them may even occur
less than one percent of the time
you're going to have the same problem
the model is going to overfit
coming back to the regression example
again here you're going to have
obnoxiously high variance
for the slope parameter estimates
associated with those levels that don't
occur very frequently
now this one you kind of have to handle
on a case-by-case basis depending on the
data and depending on the scenario
you might be able to get away with
collapsing infrequently occurring
levels into some other one category
let's call it
other but you might have to be a little
careful with that
because practically speaking those
infrequently occurring levels
might represent some things that are
dramatically different
one thing that you could do is look at
the distribution of the response
variable
for these different infrequently
occurring levels and if that looks
pretty similar
i might feel more comfortable merging
them together but broadly speaking
there is a lot of discussion to be had
on how to encode
different levels of factors so much so
that i could probably fill a whole video
with it
but for now i'll have a link in the
description of this video to a good
medium article that talks about this
number three is sort of the opposite of
the last one
you can have too much variation in your
data or more specifically
you can have outliers in certain
features now again particularly if your
sample size isn't great
this puts you at risk of overfitting the
model so from a practical standpoint
outliers should cause you to ask some
questions about how reliable the data
actually
are it could have been for that
particular observation
as far as the business process for how
that data got generated
something that time was screwed up or
unstable
and if that's the case there might be a
case to be made for eliminating that row
altogether
or at least getting rid of that outlier
and just making it an n a
but suppose your data set is completely
legitimate and yes
there are outliers in certain variables
and you just have to live with them
now certain models are more and less
sensitive to outliers than others
but even doing simple things like
normalizing your variables can make a
huge difference
another option is what's called
windsorizing the outliers
now there's no hard and fast rule on
this one but it's an interesting problem
that you'll have to address on a
case-by-case basis and i'll have two
links in the description
just detailing some of the relative
advantages and disadvantages
of windsorizing the outliers versus just
trimming them out
number four on this list should come as
no surprise to anybody
and that's having useless uninformative
variables in your model
from the standpoint of inference let's
come back to the regression model
example
and let's suppose you knew in advance
exactly which features are completely
useless
well then in that situation it wouldn't
make any sense to include these in your
model now would it
like from a worst case scenario you
might conclude that some of these are
significant
that is you make a type 1 error by
chance alone
the problem is it can be a bit of a
catch 22
because most of the time when you're
doing a regression analysis
the whole purpose is to separate out
which variables are meaningful and which
variables are meaningless
and that's where the consulting side of
data science and the domain knowledge
can really help out
maybe you can take some preliminary
regression analysis results to a
stakeholder
and let them chime in and figure out
which parts of it makes sense and which
don't
ideally before you even begin such an
analysis you'll have
some good kind of preliminary idea of
which data to include and which not to
include
and again that's probably going to be
informed by the domain knowledge rather
than the statistical expertise
and the story is similar for prediction
again if you have a lot of junk going
into your model
you're probably going to end up with a
model that overfits
now again you can get rid of
uninformative variables by using your
domain knowledge
or you can get rid of them through
regularization or feature selection
techniques
now there's one more specific case of
uninformative variables being included
in the data set to talk about
and that's multicollinearity that's
gonna be number five on this list
most people with some statistics
knowledge have at least some basic
understanding of this
it's the situation when your covariates
have some correlation with each other
and the rules for this again are not
hard and fast
but it's generally a good rule of thumb
that if a feature has a variance
inflation factor
of greater than 5 or certainly greater
than 10
then you need to do something about it
because that feature is producing
multicollinearity
and depending on your objective there
are a few different approaches you could
take next
you could drop out some of the
covariates with the high variance
inflation factor
or maybe you can just use principal
component analysis
in the regression context a variable
that has a high variance inflation
factor is going to be bad
news because that increases the variance
of the slope parameter estimate
similarly let's say you're using a
random forest model to use the feature
ranking for inference purposes
that feature ranking is going to be
unreliable if you have multicollinearity
i'll have a link in the description to a
paper which describes this topic in
greater detail
now to be fair the picture is a little
bit less clear for multicollinearity
when the goal is prediction
because for a lot of different models
multicollinearity
isn't necessarily going to be a big
issue or cause you a lot of problems
but it's certainly not going to help
either now everything that i've talked
about in this list so far
pertains to the predictors but the last
item on this list
is the situation where you have some
kind of outcome variable
but that outcome variable is poorly
trained for some reason
or just generally does not reflect
reality let me give you a personal
example for this one
so several years ago i was tasked with
building a predictive model that
predicted the onset of a certain medical
condition
well we didn't have the outcome variable
defined for that
we didn't have labels for medical
condition yes or no
so we had to use clinical feedback to
create a proxy for that outcome variable
it should be pretty self-explanatory
that regardless of your goals
if your outcome variable does not
represent reality
there is absolutely nothing that can
work well even if you build a model that
can perfectly predict that outcome
which i guarantee you you won't it's
meaningless because you're ultimately
predicting something that doesn't really
mean a whole lot
similarly you could be inferring that
some feature that you have
strongly influences that meaningless
outcome variable you've created
again that's not something that's going
to do anybody any good
in the personal example that i gave
having that proxy outcome variable
be as accurate as possible and as
closely reflect the reality on the
ground as possible
was going to be way more important than
any machine learning model that i could
throw at the problem
or probably more so even than any of the
other data issues i've talked about so
far in this video
and you'd be surprised how common it is
to see real world problems like that
even if they're maybe not as extreme as
the example that i gave
if you're not 100 sure that your outcome
variable is reliable
focus on getting it to be as reliable as
possible
so hopefully now that you've gone
through these six items you have a
pretty solid idea of why it's most
important to focus on the data
rather than the model creation itself
keep in mind this list isn't totally
comprehensive
there are other problems that can arise
out there and particularly
if your job involves being on the ground
collecting and measuring
the data that you're eventually going to
use for modeling that opens up an entire
new layer of potential data issues that
can possibly occur
but if you understand exactly how bad
data can influence a model
and you focus your efforts on the right
places you're going to be both an
efficient and an effective data
scientist
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it or you found it of value
please consider sharing this video
as well as again smashing the like
button
and also leave me a comment down below
and let me know the scenarios in which
you've personally run into bad data
yourself
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until
then richard on data